pour certains c'est un événement unique
pour d'autres un sport professionnel
une véritable passion quand j'ai fait
mon tandem j'épargne un piqûre heures
puis de [ __ ] le show de plusieurs
faiblesses ou la progression j'adore ce
c'est un sport spa technique leur en
fait on a beaucoup techniquement algérie
puis causé beaucoup de théorie c'est pas
seulement speech et en dehors dans
l'avion au cours des dernières années le
parachutisme a vu sa popularité
augmenter chez avec les années le
parachutiste comme bas des activités et
dit à risque ont gagné beaucoup en
technique s'est rendue facile s'est
rendu sécuritaire dans la maîtrise et
sow cette démocratisation du sport
extrême n'est pas une éco parachute
c'est fou en plus de l'amélioration des
techniques
l'émergence des nouvelles technologies a
permis de créer d'autres sports
repoussant encore plus loin les limites
du possible
[Musique]
comme ces combinaisons et les qui
permettent une chute libre plus longue
avant l'ouverture du parachute jusqu'à
l'os est encore assez sécuritaire ça
fait ça se fait à partir de l'avion ça
devient risqué quand les gens poussent
la limite
et puis vont sauter en wingsuit mais à
partir d'une falaise à partir d'un conte
à partir alors ça c'est des affaires
qu'on ne réussit pas au niveau du
parachutisme cette tendance aux sports
extrêmes pourraient nous laisser croire
que les accidents graves sont plus
nombreux qu'avant mais dans les faits ce
n'est pas forcément vrai les
statistiques les plus récentes
disponibles indiquent une diminution
depuis début des années 90 d'environ 35
% des décès liés aux activités
récréatives sportives
les médias sociaux sont en partie
responsables de cette fausse impression
concernant la hausse des accidents liés
aux sports extrêmes les médias et les
sports extrêmes satire mutuellement en
partie parce que les gens veulent
montrer ce qu'ils ont fait mais
également en partie parce que
l'auditoire et agir d'activité de ce
type
mais qu'est ce qui pousse l'être humain
à vouloir tester ses limites
si donc votre corps comprend qu'une
menace et un danger demeure donc le
cerveau sécrète la dopamine
une fois que le souhait terminée ben la
dopamine est encore là ce qui fait que
donc une folie le sentiment de
récompenses important et ça altère
l'état de conscience dépassement de soi
curiosité goût du risque et de la
liberté chacun a sa raison de vouloir se
jeter dans le vide et de braver les
dangers
moi ce qui me pousse beaucoup c'est par
rapport à mon handicap parce que j'ai
pas trouvé beaucoup de sport qui était
forcément adapté à sa liberté la liberté
le chili cannes c'est sûr plaisir
alors on va les voir que c'est que ça
fait on a entendu parler puis on a
l'impression ça donne on est au courant
des risques mais c'est des risques
calculés
on ne dise pas bon équipement on se
vérifie quand nous donc c'est
sécuritaire puis je pense que plus de
plaisir pour ces mordus du risque rien
ne surpasse une bonne bouffée
d'adrénaline et si jacques andré
charbonneau radio canada montréal